welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid what if I told you that everything
in optics is actually the same thing no
seriously
all of it reflection refraction
diffraction dispersion polarization
fluorescence phosphorescence Oh the same
I'd say you were crazy ha everybody just
cheer me out first of all what is optics
anyway optics is the study of how light
interacts with matter without an
interaction with matter
it's just electromagnetic theory so
let's say you shine some light into
glass surface most of the light will
pass through that's refraction but some
of the light will bounce off that's
reflection that looks like two different
things to me sure when all you do is
stare at it the law of refraction is
usually written something like this
these are called refractive indexes
which depend only on the material a
bigger change in n means a bigger
deflection in the light but what happens
when you apply it to reflection instead
the ends are the same so they cancel and
now so do the signs leaving you with
this which is just the law of reflection
they're the same oh yeah what about the
fraction smarty-pants oh that one's
really fun diffraction happens when
light spreads out after passing through
small openings so it's all about spacing
a double slit like this has a spacing of
about point seven millimeters or seven
hundred micrometers even smaller a
diffraction grating like this has a
spacing of 1.7 micrometers but let's
stick with the glass surface from
earlier yeah and how small is that
spacing atomically small a dr. nutty
Sharma actually handled this quite well
in a paper from 2003 to make some sense
of it let's look back at that glass
surface superzoom these are two atoms
that happen to be next to each other the
light comes in and hits the atom on the
Left first the one on the right has to
play a little ketchup which puts it
behind by this much then they each pass
through but now the one on the left has
to play catch-up which puts that one
behind by this much see light is a wave
and for it to exist its parts have to
line up at least a little bit
if opposite parts line up then there's
no light that's called destructive
interference if they line up perfectly
then you get the brightest light that's
called constructive
interference the space here is called
the optical path difference that
difference needs to be a whole number of
wavelengths so the wave lines up and you
get light the same thing has to happen
with these two parts the left one is off
by this much and the right one by this
much so the difference between them must
be a whole number of wavelengths doing a
little trig we get this light will go
everywhere that M equals 0 1 2 and so on
because that's where constructive
interference happens most of the light
will go where M equals 0 but what
happens there the D cancels out and we
can move some things around which is
just the law of refraction in other
words refraction is just a kind of
diffraction okay I'll bite why is it all
turning out this way glad you finally
asked if we look at this from an atomic
level in every case light is absorbed by
electrons in atoms and then released
again we call this scattering the only
difference is how it's released
reflection is backward refraction is
forward diffraction is forward an
example of which is refraction or even
backward an example of which is
reflection dispersion is just
refractions for different wavelengths or
colors which gives us things like
rainbows polarization is just refraction
through a material that can only respond
in one direction fluorescence is just
when light is released at different
wavelengths than it entered and
phosphorescence is when light is
released more slowly than it entered in
the end all optics is just the
scattering of light so how much is your
mind blown right now please share in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy